la tension est encore palpable les
salariés de la clinique sainte marie ne
savent toujours pas à quelle sauce ils
seront mangés
ce matin il s'agissait pour les juges du
tribunal administratif d'examiner le
dossier du groupe kapa actuel
propriétaire de la clinique en
redressement
un plan de continuation que capa n'a pas
présenté à ses salariés
sans rentrer dans les détails capable a
présenté une prémisse on va dire son
plan de continuation a donné un certain
nombre d'éléments toutefois pas encore
de manière
finalisez exhaustive d'autant que en
matière de procédure et par rapport aux
salariés ce plan doit être présenté hier
p ô c'est à dire au comité d'entreprise
avant qu'il puisse être débattu devant
un tribunal donc pour l'instant c'est la
raison pour laquelle puisque le comité
d'entreprise des représentants des
salariés n'ont pas encore
on leur a pas encore communiqué le
détail de ce plan de continuation ni
d'ailleurs des offres de cession le
tribunal n'était pas en mesure de
statuer sur cette question
les dirigeants de cap à seraing restent
sur leurs positions
il affirme avoir un plan solide pour
l'avenir de la clinique sainte marie
nous avons donné toutes les garanties
qu'il faut il faut les activités il faut
que le ps soit opérationnel
malheureusement d'accord et à partir de
la demande et de d'avoir d'autres
activités à la clinique d'élargir ses
activités de compléter de faire les
travaux d'améliorer pourquoi public
perdure et vous en aurez les moyens nous
en aurons le vent des moyens et pourquoi
pas maintenant qu'on sait pas fait
depuis
mais parce que vous savez c'est la santé
inssa ne se décide pas comme ça il déjà
il faut des autorisations déjà il ya des
délais à respecter
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de formes à
respecter et les salariés toujours en
attente d'une décision ne croit plus en
rien on a oublié la caserne locale
propose rien d'intéressant mais qu'ils
ne veulent pas lâcher leur hausse est
liée au jeu système à l'usure cdu c'est
chaque fois sur présente à l'audience
qu'ils avancent toujours quelque chose
et à chaque fois baisser la pression du
tribunal gates à la boisson du tribunal
même avec la veste du tribunal on est
pratiquement au ralenti un délibéré
prévu ce vendredi 28 juin aucune
décision ne sera rendue
le tribunal fixera la date de l'audience
qui décidera de la continuation ou de la
cession de la clinique sainte marie